[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN HAMNER: Good
morning, everyone,
and thanks for coming out.
My name is Ben Hamner,
and I'm the CTO of Kaggle.
And I'm here to
talk to you today
about a broad overview
of our platform
and how it may help you
in your day-to-day work.
But before I get
started, I'd like
to get a better understanding
of who's in the room
and what your background is.
I'm going to ask a
series of questions
about your exposure
to Kaggle so far.
And I want you to raise
your hand if you're familiar
or have done some of
these actions in Kaggle.
So first, can you raise your
hand if you've heard of Kaggle?
OK.
I might have to stop
asking that question,
because I think that
was the entire room.
Can you keep your hand up if
you have a Kaggle account?
Wow.
OK, about 3/4 of
the room, probably.
Then, who has downloaded
data from Kaggle?
Probably about
half the room now.
And who has entered a
Kaggle competition before?
Cool.
About 30% of the room, maybe.
Who has won a Kaggle
competition or won prize
money at a Kaggle competition?
One person at least.
Awesome.
I can have you come up
and give the talk instead.
[LAUGHTER]
And then have you written
and read code on Kaggle
through Kaggle Kernels.
Raise your hand if you have.
OK, about 10 people maybe.
About 5% of the room.
And then, have you found Kaggle
helpful to learn about data
and machine learning?
OK, about probably
40% of the room.
And then, finally, do you use
Kaggle as your primary resource
when you're starting your
journey into data, science,
and machine learning, or
starting to work with data?
Three or four people.
OK, cool.
So, it's one of the rare people.
Thanks for that to get started.
As a bit of background,
Kaggle is the world's largest
online community of data
scientists, machine learning
engineers, and AI engineers.
And we have about
2.8 million users
who come to Kaggle for
three main motivations.
First, to learn and improve
their skills working with data
and starting to work on machine
learning and AI problems
through a mix of learning
from content that we create,
content that our users
publish, as well as
competitions that we put up
that provide great test beds
for sharpening your skills.
Secondly, to compete
in the machine learning
competitions that we
host and demonstrate
how your methodologies
and techniques work
in a fair playing
ground to evaluate them
compared to thousands of
other users around the world.
And then, finally, to
collaborate on data and AI
projects as an individual
or as part of small teams
as you work on sharing
and collaborating
on code to analyze data.
And we started hosting
AI competitions in 2010.
And for most of
our history, we've
been really focused on hosting
these competitions where
companies, nonprofits and
research groups would come
to us with a large
number of machine
learning challenges
alongside datasets to address
these challenges.
And then we'd
collaborate with them
to define well-structured
AI problems on those assets
and then post them to our
community, who would then
participate in
these competitions
and develop solutions
on these datasets.
And that provided
a really great way
to gain insights into how
machine learning was evolving
as well as frictions
that users hit
as they're trying to
apply machine learning
to real problems.
And based on those pain points
and insights that we saw,
we started to expand our
platform into our community
beyond competitions in
2015 with the launch
of our reproducible research
platform in a public data
platform, as well as in 2018
the launch of our learning
resource.
So I'm going to dive deeper into
each of these parts of Kaggle.
And as I do this,
I encourage you
to think about how you
can leverage our platform
to accelerate your own
data and machine learning
work professionally.
So first as an introduction,
what is a Kaggle competition?
We run dozens of
public competitions
simultaneously, many with large
amounts of prize money attached
to them.
And each of these competitions
has a very well-defined AI
problem.
I will just walk you through
a simple example first.
This is on applying
regression techniques
as a Getting Started
tutorial competition
to predict the house prices.
And we'll start with a dataset
from a competition host
with a target variable on it.
So in this case, we're
trying to predict the sale
price of a home based on
a small number of things,
like the size of the
home, whether it's
a home or condominium, the
size of the lot it's on,
things like that.
We will take the dataset
from the competition host
and figure out a good
way to split into a train
set and a test set.
We will then release
the train set
and all but the solution on the
test set to our community, who
will then train models
on the training set
and make predictions on the
test set and then submit
their predictions back to us.
We will compare their
predictions to the ground truth
and then calculate scores
based on those predictions
on a public and
private leaderboard.
Then the really
important part of this
is participants see
real-time feedback
on how they're doing
in the competition
on the public leaderboard,
both their own score
and performance
in the competition
as well as how this compares to
every other participant in it.
And this creates
the dynamic that
really drives the progress
of the competition forward,
because it's the difference
between a user making
one or two passes
on the problem,
feeling pretty good about
themselves or pretty bad
about themselves and giving up.
And saying like, oh wow, how
did this person get ahead of me?
And then wanting to try
improving their results
to match or beat the performance
of the people in front of them.
And over time, this dynamic
drives the competition
to extract nearly all the
usable signal from the dataset,
potentially limited by the
inherent noise in the problem,
as well as any limitations in
the current state of the art
in the machine learning.
So what this graph
is going to show
is it's going to graph the
competition progress over time
and the top score on the
public leaderboard over time.
So what typically
happens is pretty quickly
we get a submission that's
a decent improvement
over the benchmark
in the competition.
And then that
submission is being
advised by another
submission that is also
a pretty large improvement.
In this dynamic, leapfrogging
occurs a couple times
early in the competition
until we hit a point
where it's very,
very tough to improve
their results beyond that.
Even with an increasing
number of teams participating
and people trying to
tackle this problem,
we don't see a large
increase in performance.
And this is a really
promising sign
that we've hit the
limit of what is
achievable on this dataset
given the current limitations
of the state of the art, as
well as any inherent noise
in the dataset.
And this is a sign,
if you're managing
a team of machine
learning engineers
as well, that you don't
want to invest more
in trying to improve the machine
learning piece of this problem.
Maybe if you're trying to
improve your performance
beyond that, you should be
collecting a lot more training
data or you should be
doing some other aspect
of the problem that isn't
based on the current dataset
that we have to work with.
Then another kind of really
unique aspect of competitions
is, even though there's a
competitive dynamic driving
them, most participants
in the competition
are not trying to win.
They're coming to learn
and improve their skills.
And this results in a highly,
highly collaborative, helpful,
and detail-oriented
competition forums
where people are sharing
what techniques work well
on the problem as well as
insights that they've learned.
As well as if they get
stuck, helping other users
get unstuck.
And this is just a quick
example of some forum post
that you'll see the really
practical detailed tips
required to do
well on the problem
versus broad statements.
And then at the end
of the competition,
final results are unveiled
on a private leaderboard
for both prize money
as well as recognition.
And to take a step back,
probably the most famous
machine learning
algorithm in the US
is the Zillow's estimate score
for estimating house prices.
And we collaborated with
Zillow at a competition
recently that involved
predicting future house price
sales and out-of-time samples.
And this actually improved
on the Zestimate by 13%.
So this provides a
really concrete example
of how this dynamic can help
improve real-world machine
learning results.
If we look at user
profiles on Kaggle,
a user's profile will highlight
their best Kaggle results
and really showcase
here's how well
they can perform on applied
machine learning problems.
And can be a critical part
to helping many of our users
find jobs, and transition
into the field, and get hired.
And alongside this, we
maintain a global ranking
of all top Kaggle
competitors over time.
The next question
I wanted to tackle
is, what use cases do our
customers tackle with Kaggle AI
competitions?
And my goal is to
give a broad overview
now of the different use
cases that we tackle.
This isn't going to
cover everything,
but it's going to be a
representative sample.
The first set
that's become really
prominent in recent years
based on the combination
of the success of
deep learning as well
as widely available
image datasets and cost
effective human
labeling has fostered
a large growth in computer
vision competitions.
And these range from
image classification,
object boundary detection,
and object recognition
to environmental problems
like detect facial recognition
in whales or counting
how many sea lions
that you see in images there.
A subset of this category
that I'm personally
really excited about is
using automated methodologies
to improve medical
imaging results
and start to tackle the
challenge that we only
have a very small number
of trained physicians
in the world, relative to the
size of the global population,
who can read these images.
And that means
that we're missing
results of a huge fraction
of the population.
One example of that
was we collaborated
with a company called MobileODT
that's developing a device that
can be attached to a cell phone
for cervical cancer imaging
and then can flag, if it's
for patients in rural Africa,
if they should be seeing a
doctor in a followup visit
and going to an urban city to
see a doctor and a follow-up
visit on that.
A third broad category, moving
back to the online world,
is around recommender systems
and personalized recommender
systems where these have been
very effective at improving
results ranging from
consumer products
to things that are directly
useful for machine learning
engineers as well,
like recommending which
of our packages you should be
using in your day-to-day work.
Another distinct
and more challenging
stat is forecasting
product demand over time
on out-of-time samples,
where you can no longer make
the assumption that past
performance or past results are
going to be drawn from
the same distribution
of the future results.
And this introduces a
really complex time element
into the machine learning
models in the forecasts that
need to be done for
tackling these challenges.
Another broad category that is
a really important challenge
to solve is
improving our ability
to apply automated methods for
text and speech understanding,
especially with a large
increase in online content
recently into everything
that that entails.
And then, finally, looking at
some more industrial use cases,
we've started to
see an increasing
number of predictive
maintenance use cases
for predicting which parts will
require maintenance over time
in advance of the part failing
and the maintenance being
required.
So, next, I want to
look at what insights
have we learned from
seeing how users
approach these competitions.
And the first is probably
everyone's favorite topic
when they look at
what works well
in machine learning, which is
what tools and techniques work
well?
Over the past
several years, that
has a pat, a really
pithy summary.
And there's tooled
types of techniques
that have been
omnipresent in winning
a lot of different types
and diverse types of Kaggle
competitions.
The first are flavors of
ensemble decision trees,
like radium-boosted
machines with XGBoost
is one of the really common
successful high-quality
implementations of that.
And then secondly--
deep neural networks
for virtually-structured
natural input,
like computer vision
data, with Keras
as being one example of a really
popular library implementing
that.
And we actually
recently surveyed
Kaggle winners since 2016 for
which primary ML framework
were they using.
And then you see
this, coming out here,
where we have three deep
learning frameworks that
stood out as the primary
framework the winners had
used--
Keras, PyTorch, and TensorFlow.
And then two--
ensemble decision tree
gradient boosting machine
frameworks, LightGBM
and XGBoost.
And these are so widely used
both because of their ease
of use and ease of getting
started on challenges
as well as the ability to go
really deep and iterate quickly
and expose the complexity
when you need it
in improving the machine
learning algorithms
that you're using to tackle
the specific problem.
We also added a secondary
question to that survey--
for what auxiliary ML software
tools are you also using
to compete in competitions?
And the one that
really stood out here
is, SciKit Learn was rarely
used as the primary tool
by the winners.
However, the feature
pre-processing and the feature
selection and
ensembling techniques
that were present in it were a
highly helpful auxiliary tool
for our different winners.
From a process
standpoint, we've also
had one clear lesson that
has stood out from hundreds
of winner's interviews.
And that is-- the
people who do well
at applying machine learning
do not take a complex idea,
then try that one
complex idea over
a three-month to
12-month time period.
Because a lot of ideas that
we start off with are bad.
Instead, what they do is
they optimize their workflow
for learning and experimenting
through a lot of bad ideas
to find the ones that actually
work or start working well,
and then really honing in
on the ideas that work well.
So instead of
trying to implement
one large and complex
idea, they instead
try many ideas over time,
implement them quickly,
evaluate how they work,
analyze their results
and what they learned, and
then go through this cycle
again and again and again.
And the teams that
perform well are the teams
that are effective at both going
through the cycle many times
as well as paying
close attention to what
they were learning from
going through the cycle.
And in a similar
vein, this iteration
is not just done on the
single layer machine
learning component.
Instead, for any
applied AI model,
you go from an interim component
from a business problem
to a production system.
That includes finding
source datasets to use.
How do you split
the data in order
to do your internal
evaluation, as well as
your final evaluation samples?
Which evaluation
metrics do you use?
How do you extract features
and select features?
How do you train your model?
How do you do model selection?
And finally, how
do you implement
that in a production system?
Our competitions don't
currently tackle the first piece
in the last piece of
that in the darker blue.
But some of our competitions
tackle the interim pieces
in between those.
And it's critical to optimize
those entire workflows, not
just that machine learning
piece in the middle there.
And given this rapid
iteration and a large number
of experiments that
our users are running,
another key piece that
successful participants do
is they keep very careful
track of all their experimental
results for their learning, as
well as using version controls
so they can scroll
back at a point in time
when they need to go back to
an idea that had some promise,
and pull that back up, and
really understand what worked
about it and what drove that.
Another piece-- and this
has been true for almost all
of the several hundred general
competitions that we've run--
is that they've been won by
large ensembles of models
versus a single model.
And these large ensembles
almost always eke out
very marginal additional gain.
So it's like, the single
best model in there
might be 99.5% of
the best performance.
Then that additional 0.5%
performance improvement
comes from taking a large number
of different complex models
and combining them
all together, which
is great for squeezing
out the last bit
of predictive accuracy.
But putting my software
engineering hat on,
it's about the last thing I'd
want to put into production.
So instead, we'll focus on that
single best performing model
within that ensemble.
That is the one that
might make more sense
to put in production.
Another lesson
that we've learned
is, successful
participants very analyze
how does their model
generalize in new data points
and try avoiding overfitting.
One of our users
learned this lesson
the hard way when he
watched himself fall off
the leaderboard in the final
minute of the competition when
it transitioned from
the public leaderboard
to the holdout set in
the private leaderboard.
And I don't think
he's ever failed
a competition since then.
So I want to talk
a little bit more
about where we are going
with Kaggle AI competitions.
Almost every competition
that we've run so far
has been of the form--
we have a training dataset
and a test dataset.
Users download the
training dataset,
make predictions on the trainer
model and the training dataset,
make predictions
on the test asset,
and upload their
predictions to Kaggle.
Uploading predictions is
limiting in a number of ways.
So we're starting to expand
the competitions that we're
hosting beyond
uploading predictions
and to uploading code and
using the code as a submission.
So the way this works for a
small number of competitions
now is users will write
the code to train the model
and make predictions of it,
through a code execution
service that we run and then
submit that code to Kaggle.
A couple examples
of this where it's
been really helpful to enable
us to run these competitions
in a high-quality
way is two of them
have touched on back
testing and forecasting
time series in a
financial modeling problem
where, for any time
series challenge,
you don't want to have a single
trained asset and test asset.
And instead, you want
to stream the data
into the model over time and
make predictions going forward
at each time increment.
It's also helped us run more
effective competitions around
challenges where a human
could go through and label
the answers to the results,
because we can now run
competitions on
hidden test assets,
where a human can actually
go through in hand-label
the results of the test set--
like for text or
image competitions.
And then finally, it's let us
experiment with competitions
around adversarial learning.
We have a really fun
cat-and-mouse dynamic where--
let's say that I have
a picture of a cat
and I want to
trick my classifier
into thinking this is a
picture of a dog, not a cat,
by making small, imperceptible
modifications to that picture.
And then we ran a
series of competitions
around predicting models
that modify images
to trick classifiers,
as well as models
that should classify
those images
and be robust against
those adversarial attacks.
And in the future,
this will unlock
a bunch of exciting new
flavors of AI competitions,
ranging from backtesting time
series and live data feeds
to reinforcement
learning challenges,
where instead of a
machine learning model
making predictions, you have
an agent that's taking actions
and interacting
with an environment.
And it's scored based on how it
interacts with that environment
over time.
As well as generative
modeling competitions,
where you are creating new
images or new tech samples
and evaluating
whether or not those
images or text samples mirror
the real distributions.
Adversarial learning
competitions--
that's another one
that I mentioned.
Another area that's become
increasingly important,
as machine learning
has moved out
of research and into
many applications
throughout the world,
is machine learning
under computational constraints.
Because if you're implementing
machine learning at scale,
it is very costly to do the
machine learning predictions,
both in terms of dollars
and energy usage,
as well as there's
a lot of scenarios
where you want a very low
latency and low energy
predictions.
For example, I could have
the best speech recognition
model in the world.
But if I'm in a low-connectivity
scenario with my cell phone,
that model is useless to me
if it can't [? broaden ?]
quickly on my phone.
And then finally, it will let
us run competitions on sensitive
datasets where we cannot
release the dataset publicly
but, instead, we can bring
the code and the models
to the datasets privately.
Now, as I mentioned before, we
spent most of the past decade
or so focused on building
and expanding AI competitions
in the community around that.
But more recently, we've been
building beyond AI competitions
as well.
And I wanted to talk a little
bit about our motivations
for that.
So the global community that
we built around competitions
has provided a lot of
insight for current frictions
on applying AI through
our experience working
with hundreds of hosts and
organizations around the world
and seen their frictions
that they structured
in creating machine
learning problems
and deploying the
datasets for those,
from our experience in
working with our users
and seeing how they
started tackling problems
and all the frictions
they had doing things
like sharing code
with each other,
as well as from our
own internal work.
And I'll summarize
some of the ones that
have served as inspiration
for me and for us,
as we start to expand
beyond competitions.
The first is that
we've hit many barriers
to accessing data,
which still lives
in silos within
different organizations
and many different forms.
And then, once we do
have access to that data,
understanding the
context behind the data
makes you feel like a detective.
And getting that data
into a high-quality state
can be really tough.
For a couple examples that we've
hit, trying to clean data--
one of them is, I was working
with a dataset of flight
arrival and departure
times for training models
to predict how long
a flight will take.
And then on the
first pass of it,
I was surprised to see that
I had a bunch of flights
that had negative duration.
Then I was thinking, oh, OK.
I must have messed up the time
zone processing in my code
or something like that.
I look at that-- no.
Time zones were right,
including for flights taking off
and landing in the time zone.
For whatever reason, there's
just a couple percentage
of these flights that were
put in incorrectly as actually
landing before they took
off, which made no sense.
And then, if I'm
trying to make a model
to predict flight
durations, then I naively
throw a bunch of flights
with negative duration
in there, that'll throw
my entire results way off.
As another example--
I was working with a
dataset of bulldozer prices.
And one of the fields
as an input into that
was the year the bulldozer
was manufactured.
I was flipping through
that and see things
like 1983, 1995, 1972.
I'm thinking, OK,
this makes sense.
Then I start seeing
a bunch of fields
that say 1000, 1000, 1000.
And bulldozers didn't exist
before the steam engine.
It didn't exist
in the year 1000.
It turns out that, somewhere
in the complex set of processes
to create that dataset from
a lot of different sources,
one person decided,
you know what?
1,000 is a great number
to use as a missing value.
So 1,000 just meant
that they didn't
know when it was manufactured.
And as a third example--
we were working with a
dataset of student essays
that we had transcribers
go and digitize those
with the instructions that--
if you can't read the essay,
please, throw it out.
And don't send us the
data back for that.
And mark it as,
you can't read it.
Instead, we were starting
to train some baseline
models on this and saw that
there was one essay in there--
and these were supposed to
be about 1,000-word essays--
that just said, this
essay got good marks.
But as far as I can
tell, it's gibberish
that scored very highly.
And if I'd actually thrown that
into a machine learning model
with a very small
number of datasets
that would have really
thrown my model off.
Because there was a case
where that transcriber
didn't follow the instructions.
Then pretty much
any data problem
like this has a large number
of examples where you really
need to dig deep into
that asset to understand
the context behind it's created
and what errors may exist
with it, to successfully apply
machine learning models that
work well on it.
And another flavor of
that is understanding
which forms of leakage
may emerge near the asset.
It's a really common
and subtle problem
for a lot of machine
learning applications.
Leakage is where you're
trying to use information
to make predictions
on the new samples
that you don't actually have at
the time of making predictions.
That new sample source is
invalid to use for predictions
and new samples.
And one example of this
is, we got a dataset
a while ago on prostate
cancer prediction
and trying to predict the
likelihood of a patient
to have prostate cancer.
It had a couple
hundred fields in there
with [INAUDIBLE]
obscurely named that we
didn't know what they meant.
So we trained a
baseline model on it,
then looked at what was
driving the results.
And it turns out, this
innocuously named feature,
prossurg, was
buried in the middle
of that that represented--
this patient had had
surgery for prostate cancer.
So it's highly, highly
predictive of whether or not
the patient was likely
to have prostate cancer,
but was entirely useless in
applying in any new patient
scenario.
Then another kind of common
pain point that we've seen is--
reproducing others' work
can take a very long time,
whether I'm going back to work
that I did four years ago,
I'm trying to take work that
my colleague did and run it
on my machine, or--
even worse-- starting
with a rated paper that's
published online that
I'm really interested in,
but I don't have the
code data or maybe even
the computational equipment
that was used to produce that,
and trying to reproduce
those results.
So this is probably one of the
largest wastes of human capital
and resources in our
field and that we
spend a tremendous
amount of time
simply trying to get to the same
results that someone else had,
in working through
packaged conflicts, version
conflicts, different data
sets, and a large set of errors
there, simply to reproduce work
that someone else had already
did.
That brings us to
the first product
that we launched to try starting
to address some of these pain
points.
I see a lot of the
frictions I mentioned
as aspirational long-term goals.
And if we can even make
a small dent into those,
then we can create some
real good in the world.
So first, we've launched a
feature called Kaggle Kernels,
where you can now click New
Kernel on any competition
or dataset on Kaggle.
And this will enable you to
spin up an interactive script
or notebook session in
Python or R on that dataset
and in a docker container.
And you, within seconds, will
have a source code editor,
an interactive console, and the
raw data at your fingertips,
so you don't have to do
things like install packages,
because we have most of the
Python and R open source
package ecosystems
installed in there for you.
You don't have to worry
about downloading the data
or going into the data
or anything like that.
So it's also easy to moderate
things like your compute usage
and add GPUs or additional
compute if you need to in this.
And after you finish coding
or get to a stopping point,
you can click Commit
and then create
a sharable and reproducible
version of your work
in a clean environment.
The reason we rerun things
in clean environments is--
I've seen a lot of
Jupyter notebooks
where it might have
15 cells in it.
But those 15 cells have
been run about 1,000 times.
And what was in the cell
included a lot of hidden stage
that was necessary to
reproduce the work,
so it's not actually
reproducible.
And then from here, you
can share your kernel
with collaborators
or make it public
and share it with our community.
And then we've had, now, a very
large number of high-quality
kernels shared
publicly on Kaggle--
over about 200,000, now
of which about 50,000
have at least one upvote
from another user,
as a rough indication for--
another user found
this valuable.
And this is a higher
quality result.
And in practice,
this means we now
have a really rich array
of content for, basically,
any type of data that
you might be working with
and machine learning problem
or visualization problem
that you might be
trying to tackle.
You can find an example of how
to do that in a public dataset
on Kaggle.
So it's helped provide a
really rich way of tutorials
that you can use to
get started with.
And furthermore,
because this is being
backed by versioned
compute, versioned data,
and versioned code, it's
straightforward to fork
others' kernels that
they have shared here
and reproduce the
work that they created
as well as interact
with their examples
and extend it into your own.
So I see a kernel
that's combining
the three critical components
for reproducible data science.
The first is versioned code.
The second is versioned data.
And the third is a versioned
computational environment
through docker containers.
And then things on Kaggle
are mostly reproducible,
in the sense that you can
still do things like not
set a random seed or, if
you're using parallelism,
a lot of functions that
use parallelism have
a dependency on the time
they take to execute
and for whatever
results are returned.
So it's not reproducible
in that sense,
but it's reproducible in
many of the core senses.
That brings us to one of
the next questions we face.
Well, we've launched
kernels in competitions.
But I want to load new data
into that kernel as well.
How do I do that?
And that led us to
launch Kaggle Datasets
for two different reasons.
The first was to provide a
versioned and reproducible data
storage to load
data into kernels.
That was straightforward, to
drag files up and drop them in,
where they're in a versioned
way for future use.
And then secondly, to
provide an interface
where it was easy to share
data in a high-quality way
to the rest of the world.
And over the past
couple of years,
this has grown
really dramatically.
And about 15,000
datasets have now
been publicly shared on Kaggle.
And my longer-term goal is
to have all the public data
in the world accessible through
a common interface like this,
so I no longer--
if I'm trying to work
with weather data,
for example-- have to go
to an FTP server from NOAA
to try getting that obscure
weather that I'm trying to pull
in, or I'm trying to dig through
a complex data dictionary
from the census to
understand-- what does
this field in the census,
as one of the most commonly
used datasets, mean?
Then all of these datasets
are downloadable and browsable
in web UI.
And we're really
targeting making
these datasets easy to consume
both for humans and machines.
So the machine piece is
connecting it to Kaggle Kernels
and, for ease of use for
consumption, in Python and R.
And the human piece is providing
clear summaries of what's
in the data for
things like histograms
on the number of unique
values in a field,
the number of missing
values in the field,
as well as collaborative human
written descriptions of--
what's does this column mean?
What does this file mean?
What's in this file?-- and
components along those lines.
And these datasets
link all the code
that users have publicly
shared on top of them as well.
So if you go and publish
it out on Kaggle,
you get the advantage of
seeing how that is used
and how other users have
built on your dataset
and created code
on your dataset.
And then if you're trying to
get started on the dataset,
then you don't just start
with an Excel spreadsheet
or a CSV file or
the file itself.
Instead, you start with--
here's 1,000 different
code examples
that other users have written
on it for how to read that data
and how to visualize it,
how to pre-process it,
how to apply machine
learning algorithms to it,
and things along those lines.
And then, after we'd started
to build up all these resources
and create all this
content in Kaggle,
we started to get the
question more and more--
I want to get started
with machine learning,
and I do not know where to go.
What should I do?
And that led us
to start building
a series of micro-courses
with tutorials
and interactive exercises
with a goal of providing
a really fast and
straightforward way for users
to get started in the
nearest way possible,
to get them onto their own
projects and their own work.
So these range from
beginner content like Python
and interest in machine
learning and data visualization.
And on Pandas, there's a really
nice database manipulation
library in Python--
to more advanced
content, like machine
learning
explainability, a course
where we want to really
help users understand that--
I'm seeing machine
learning models
as black boxes is a really
common misconception.
And there's a large number
of tools and methodologies
available to you to introspect
a machine learning model
and to understand what is
driving its performance.
And why is it making the
predictions that it is.
So that was a broad overview
of the different pieces
of Kaggle's platform.
I hope that was helpful
for you to understand
the different components
of what we're working on
and why we're working
on them, as well as
when you're trying to solve your
next machine learning or data
problem, hopefully this will
be a helpful resource for you
to go to and find an example
as a source of inspiration
or see how another
user has tried
to tackle a similar
problem as you,
and use that as a starting
point versus needing
to start your work
from a blinking cursor.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]